yo we're gaben max here in the center of
fashion whether we're in the hottest
nightclub before the hottest boardroom
we do everything with style that's why
we've teamed up with details magazine
and give you all the tips you need to
get your style good to go I'm loving it
as known style experts guys are always
hitting on us with questions so let's
check out a letter from the mailbag Tony
writes in so what's man style anyway
only owning silk underwear shut up Tony
there are four pillars have to erect
inside yourself to have man style the
first pillar is only owning silk
underwear looks like Tony's a lucky
guesser the second pillar confidence
you can never be too overconfident
you're a few real life examples of how
you can demonstrate confidence do you
have much money I have you know how much
money I have but sometimes you might
experience a confidence crisis part of
man style staying cool under pressure no
how much money do you have that look
pretty confident game who cares never
don't be confident colors please yeah
this next pillar needs no introduction
you always need to wear a little bit of
makeup just a little bit in the morning
and a touch-up before you go out at
night and carry a small bag of makeup
with you for touch up come on max these
guys aren't idiots they know now that
you've got your silk underwear your
confidence and your makeup on time to
just be yourself your personality
defines your man style for example my
personality is owning three track suits
my personality is venti latte there are
many personalities that can define you
pick yours bluetooth casual risky
businessman elegant father professor
chill old rafidi CEO and remember be
yourself we hope that answer your
questions Tony but remember man style is
a journey not just a destination we gave
you the pillars but they can take years
to Iraq gave it hire professionals and
we're still working on our erections
you